good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about how you can be more
persuasive rule number two is my
personal favorite and I'm curious if
you're growing which one you guys like
the best and as always guys as you're
listening if you hear something that
really really resonates with you please
leave it in the comments below and put
quotes around it so other people can be
inspired and also as you write things
down you're much more likely to keep it
in here as well enjoy
[Music]
what I want you to get is it the single
most important skill of life we hate the
word selling so I'll give you a word
that it really is that doesn't have the
negative connotation it's the word that
all leaders have what would that word be
influenced what changes companies is
leaders the only way to change the
company is leadership and I want to
change the company that I own and I want
to make a shift in their company the
number one thing I'm going to do is
shifting leadership that might be taking
leaders to a different level that I
bring new leaders in that buy me new
leaders of new voices with new
perspectives with new skill sets new
directions but we need to take things
from available leaders solve problems
and leaders maximize resources if you're
going to solve problems you can't do it
yourself it would already been called
you have to get others to help you to do
it
that requires influence true you need to
get people to maximize resources that
requires influence if you're going to
get people to partner with you provide
you resources capital suppliers anything
that requires influence if you can have
an impact on your kids or your community
or the world that requires influence
there is no more important skill of
leadership than influence and yet most
of us think of it like selling and as a
result we don't master influence because
I know that if you can't influence you
can't lead but if you can influence
powerfully intelligently with integrity
there's no limit to whatever you can
envision and what you can make real and
if your influence becomes not just use
the influence that you're able to
influence systems people company culture
if you can turn other people into
influencers now whatever you vision
about can be made into reality
so let me give you a hypothetical
suppose that you're a parent and you
have a daughter say a teenage daughter
whose room is an absolute mess it just
looks like a bomb went off in there
and you want your daughter to clean your
room you're trying to sell her on the
idea of cleaning her room what do you do
well you could try to bribe her and that
might work in the short term you could
try to threaten her that might work in
the short term you can try to exhort her
you can try to you know tell her about
the meaning of clean rooms but there's
actually a technique from actually the
counseling literature really
crystallized by a fellow named Mike
pantalon of Yale University called
motivational interviewing and what you
can do more effectively is ask to
irrational questions so let's say that
you have a daughter named Maria and
Maria has a messy room and you want
Maria to clean her room the two
questions you could ask Maria are this
Maria on a scale of 1 to 10 1 meaning
I'm not ready at all 10 meaning I'm
ready to do it right now how ready are
you Maria to clean your room now Maria's
room is a pigsty so she's not going to
give a very she's not going to give you
a 10 or a 9 or even a 5 maybe she'll
give you a 2 okay so she says dad I'm a
- well here's where the second question
comes in and it's a really interesting
counterintuitive question you say to
Maria okay Maria you're a - why didn't
you pick a lower number
now our instincts as parents is to say
as a parent of three kids I have this
instinct very strongly my kid were to
say to me I'm a - I would say why are
you a - you should be a nine but you say
why didn't you pick a lower number of
Maria so here's what happens Maria has
to explain why she isn't a one okay and
so she says well you know I am 15 and I
probably should get my act together you
know if I had my room cleaner I'd be
able to get to school on time faster and
maybe see my friends a little bit more
you know you and Mom never know where
anything is anyway so I'm kind of
wasting my time asking you to help me
what happens with that second question
why didn't you pick a lower number
Maria begins articulating her own
reasons for doing something and this is
really axiomatic and sales and
persuasion when people have their own
reasons for doing something not yours
their own reasons for doing something
they believe those reasons more deeply
and adhere to the behavior more strongly
[Music]
now suppose Maria says dad on a scale of
1 to 10 I'm a 1 okay that makes things a
little more complicated but it's
actually a really really important to
understand this if you say to Maria if
Maria says that I'm a 1 here's what you
say to Maria Maria what can we do to
make you a 2 and what often that does is
this Maria will say well maybe if you
and Mom help me for 15 minutes to get
this started maybe if you maybe not set
the table and take out the trash tonight
that would free up some time for me
because usually when people are a 1 it's
often because not because they're purely
obstinate it's because there's some kind
of environmental obstacle in front of
them and if you if someone says there
are one find out what that obstacle is
try to make them a 2 and that might give
you some more momentum the the example I
just gave had to do with with parenting
but you can use this more universally
now you can't whip it out at every
single persuasive encounter but you can
use it to persuade your boss you can use
it maybe to persuade a reluctant
prospect in an actual sales encounter
you can you can use it with someone your
neighbor who's resisting moving his
garbage cans or something like that the
key here and again you got to go back to
first principles here the key here is
that we tend to think that persuasion or
motivation is something that one person
does to another and what the social
science tells us very clearly is that
it's really something that people do for
themselves and your job as a persuader
as a motivator is to reset the context
in surface people's own reasons for
doing something because it works a lot
better every phone call you make is
recorded there's no single phone call
that goes in turn out in North America
that they have ever recording up and
they can
search by word by tone by tempo they can
even recognize voices now there is no
thinking of such thing as privacy
everything you've ever put on the
Internet is there forever
and people know it and can search it the
way you write is searchable now you
cannot sign your email you can put on
somebody else's email and the structure
of your language and the way you
influence things can be study at this
level so the good news about that is
manipulation as a ongoing tool to
success is over but adding value will
never go out of style truth will never
go out of style
so influencing with integrity is the
secret but what really influences people
do facts and figures we give you the
facts and figures out of course stories
that can influence people
no it's deleting that story together in
a way that produces what shifts people
and apps human emotion ultimately the
big game here is emotion you look the
influence of motion you have to
influence see most of your people if
you're going to maximize resources and
if we all agree as we talked about the
other day it's not a lack of resources
it's a lack of what resourcefulness if
you're creative enough if your playful
enough if your determine enough if
you're focused enough you can find a way
if you're giving enough if you're
generous enough if you're honest enough
if you're courageous enough you will get
people to help you you will find the way
you will make that thing happen you'll
access the resource you got someone to
coach you teach you loan it to you let
you try it drive it experience it so
it's the ability to influence emotions
because that's what affects our
intellect that's about a month our core
story is only there to give you a set of
facts to educate someone that will make
them emotional up to make a decision and
what they do is they go through a series
of things that you have emotions about
it may save them in an unemotional way
but the only reason they work is because
you know they're to open the person's
emotion I don't agree with you on the
side so as leaders we can never forget
the humans are emotional creatures
including ourselves and to influence
other people we have to know what
already influences them
we can't ever forget what truly
influences them it's going to come down
to our ability to connect
at a deep emotional level or get others
to do the same men and women with
charisma and personal magnetism almost
invariably have a clear vision of who
they are where they're going and of what
they're trying to achieve and you can
develop this as well
leaders in sales and management have a
vision of what they're trying to create
and why they're doing what they're doing
they're focused on accomplishing some
great purpose with their lives and their
work they're decisive about every aspect
of their lives they know exactly what
they want
and what they have to do to get it they
plan their work and they may work their
plan you can increase your charisma and
the magnetism of your personality by
setting clear goals for yourself making
plans to achieve them and then working
on your plans with discipline and
determination every day the whole world
seems to move aside for the person who
knows exactly where is going in fact the
clearer you are about your purposes and
goals the more likely people will be to
attribute other positive qualities to
you well you're clear about your goals
people will see you or perceive you as
being a better and more admirable human
being and when you have clear goals you
begin attracting to yourself the people
and opportunities necessary to make
those goals a reality in robert
cialdini's book influence he says a
well-known principle of human behavior
says that when we ask someone to do a
favor we will be more successful if we
provide a reason here's an example from
that book listen to this a woman was
standing in line for a copy machine and
she said excuse me I have five pages may
I go ahead of you and make my copy 60
percent of people said yes now listen to
this
she tried asking a slightly different
way she gave a reason why this time she
said excuse me I have five pages may I
use the copy machine because I'm in a
rush and this time 94% of the people
said yes
one and a half times as many that is a
lot of persuasion now there's more to
that study and you can check it out
shielding these books but the point here
is that when you give people a reason
why you're asking for something they're
more inclined to give it to you how do I
add more value so that I can get paid
more so that I can have more influence
so that I can make more of a difference
where I'm adding everyone you always
hear all the time right add more value
well how how do you add more value so
you can get paid more and have more
influence part of adding value is
helping people reconnect with some
emotional side of their lives I know
that sounds so simple in some ways but
also philosophical that a lot of what we
experience today in this world is is
just so cheap and so commoditized and so
technically driven that it's our job if
we want to add a lot of value to bring
back in humanity
to bring back in the emotion to bring
back in the color the flair the joy the
vibrancy the real hues of human emotion
that are often missing from everything
if you bring that back into everything
that you're contributing you'll go to a
level of adding value that most people
never understand and people won't just
follow you because you're the person who
asked the question best questions if you
won't just follow you because you're the
person who knows the most people people
will follow you because you're an
inspire and you're a leader because they
can see within you that you have true
energy true engagement to human emotion
with everything you could contributing
and because of that they know that
you're somebody they want to follow so
my take on this is if you want to be
more persuasive then you need to care
more you need to care more and the care
comes from two sides first is you caring
more about it yourself having more
passion in it when you have passion when
you're extended about something people
want to join you people want to be
around people who are passionate about
something you can gear somebody towards
something because you have the passion
for it Sam Walton from Walmart used to
say that passion is so important and
that people will catch it like a fever
you have a fever this people will catch
it you have a cold other people will
catch it you have a passion other people
will catch it so if you want to be more
persuasive when you're saying these
words
it's really going to help somebody
whatever it is you're positive service
you're trying to promote your book your
YouTube channel whatever it is if you
are excited and it comes through in
every word that comes out of your mouth
it's going to be much more persuasive to
the people listening and if you're
really boring and saying yeah I have a
youtube channel you should check it out
there's some good stuff on there it's
just a different vibe you don't want to
go check that thing out when somebody's
excited like I want a piece of that I
want more excitement and passion in my
life and so I'm going to go check it out
so that happens when you care more so
care more and tie into the why and
remember before going into every
conversation why this is so important to
you and to them the second part of care
is caring about that caring about their
best interest caring about what they
want to do in their life in their
business in the results that they are
trying to achieve and how you can
potentially help them if you have a
product or service that can help
somebody solve a critical problem then
it's your responsibility to show your
care to them if they can feel that you
actually care about them that you're not
just trying to sell them your product or
service that you actually treat down
care about their success they're going
to be much more receptive to it you're
going to be much more persuasive to them
I think with all of this not just about
trying to convince somebody to do
something that they don't really want to
do I think the ultimate persuasion comes
from helping them realize that this is
something that they want to do that your
product or service will actually help
them if you look at my youtube videos I
don't care if you guys watch every video
I'd actually prefer that you don't watch
every video I want you to watch the
videos that have the most meaning the
impact to you and then go take some kind
of action the best thing from YouTube's
perspective is spend all day long on
YouTube watching my videos I don't want
that to happen I want you to watch some
videos and then go take action stop
watching and go do something in your
life or your business and if you need to
watch these videos as a way to get more
inspiration to get more motivation to
get more strategies and tactics and
ideas to do something that's great make
that part of your daily routine amazing
and then go take some action and
hopefully you feel that care that I have
for you guys I deeply want you to be
successful I want more than I want you
to be on my youtube channel I want you
to have success with your plan I want
this year to be amazing for you I want
you to get this thing out of your head
and out into the world having a big
impact making a lot of money having the
life that you want to
of and reaching your potential this is
what fuels me and so when I speak like
that when I connect with people in that
way they feel the care that I have for
them and that makes a huge huge
difference so my tip to be more
persuasive is to care care more for
yourself care more about the passion you
have for the product to service an
industry that you're in and then care
more about the customer help them
achieve the objective that they want to
achieve and show them that you're not
just trying to make a sale we're trying
to help them live a better life or have
a better business care more
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because soo shmita ogia
asked me to so there's a topic you'd
like me to cover in the next edition of
the leave life
leave it down the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I also love to
know what did you learn from this video
what was your favorite clip and why how
are you going to be more persuasive or
do you have a tip that you'd like to
share as well please leave it down in
the comments below I'm excited to see
what you guys have to say finally I want
to give a quick shout out to Fabian
Fabian thank you so much for the
interview and for picking up a copy of
my book your one word it really really
really means a lot to me and I hope
you're enjoying the read so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is much love have an amazing day and
I'll see you soon
how to persuade people it is virtually
impossible unless you want to get lotto
to get lucky you can hit lotto if you
remember the lucky sperm Club you and
evidence from your from your parents
right well maybe yeah you can circumvent
this this that that process but it's
really about seeing the world as it is
right now accurately not worse than its
but seeing the world accurately then
seeing the world better than it is and
then developing a strategy to get there
and one of the cornerstones strategies
for that is being able to persuade to
influence to make your thoughts known in
a way that empowers people and get you
what you want to